only on CBS this morning we spoke to
juror number nine in the landmark trial
of disgraced Hollywood mogul r-v
Weinstein drew who asked only to be
identified by his first name was one of
the seven men on the 12-person jury we
sat down with him in New York City
yesterday he told us about the emotional
and physical toll that the develop that
the deliberations she's trying to say
took on him and the other jurors and
about the pressure they all felt to be
objective in the most watched case of
the me2 era I want to go back to that
moment said the People vs Harvey
Weinstein and you're in that court and
you think what what are the chances you
know that of the people who were
subpoenaed for jury duty the
happenstance was it was mind blowing
what did you know about Harvey Weinstein
and the case probably not as much as
others but obviously you know some he
would heard about the case certainly yes
Ronan Farrow The New Yorker New York
Times things of things of that nature
here you are drew you're selected one of
the seven men are you nervous a lot of
people have asked me you know how can
you be impartial in a trial like this
and that's a good question why I take
absolute pride in my objectivity judge
Burk instructed us he said you can know
who Harvey Weinstein is and still be
impartial and I agree with him a hundred
percent one juror has described it as a
tense situation the tension and because
of the professionalism and the civility
of each juror was not person-to-person
it wasn't confrontational it was not we
this is heavy heavy stuff heavy stuff
this is a you know people are baring
their souls on the stand listen
12 people you know me and 11 strangers
everybody brings their own belief system
and its life experience in clinician's
inspirations motivations but it was our
job that was put to us to be impartial
and to interpret the law and to render
unanimous verdict
in the case did you ever have breakdowns
yourself thinking about it I had a rough
moment once I kind of found myself just
you know I was holding my head kind of
what tearing up I don't know yeah it was
just just sad and I turned actually to
one of the other Joe jurors and I said I
said thanks for being my friend
in retrospect it's such a silly a silly
thing to say it's not but it was it was
like I had like cut myself open and and
dumped it all out for everybody to see
and instead of judging me for it they
kind of all put me back together again
so dude that's not a silly thing to say
no I understand it's you know that's a
human thing to say it's just the the
word choice is funny to me now but I was
in everything every day was very
emotional I want to know the process in
the deliberations take us inside what
would happen there I think helpful
suggested that I had made was that we
that we take a different seat on each
day of the deliberation not not during
the trial why did you want to do that
well because I think it's a change of
perspective quite literally you know
yeah but also you know if you sit next
to the same person every day it's kind
of an echo chamber of affirmation just
to avoid any type of groupthink or or
even sub conscious gestures to want to
know their own it would also give you a
different seat partner every day yes
exactly
so to just force yourself quite
literally out of your comfort zone might
also force you to take a more objective
approach to what we're talking about did
the men feel one way and the women feel
you know I get asked that a lot
yeah I'm curious know there was was
there any break there was no gender
there was no gender bias there was no
race bias it no and I and I thanked them
on four or five occasions just for the
civility you heard that according to the
prosecution
Harvey Weinstein went to great lengths
to hire companies to
get information on his accusers
obviously we deliberated about it but if
I was rich and powerful and I heard the
people we're talking about me I would
hire an investigation for him to find
out what they're talking about and
that's really all we deduced from that
was this a tough verdict to reach to get
a unanimous decision I understand that
people have an interest and a desire to
know but this is how we found on these
counts and I see I see no upside to kind
of pulling back the curtain are you
comfortable with your decision well that
is an interesting question and the
answer is yes and and to speak to the
respect I have for the people in the
room we have to live with these choices
it was interesting because I said you
know at times a the testimony became
very emotional for mana bellusci or I'm
from from Jessica man it was very
emotional wrenching he says to watch but
their job was to focus on did it happen
on this particular day what they were
saying they didn't look at the before
they didn't look at the after and he was
very good at quoting the dates and
quoting the details of the case he was
so meticulous in explaining his process
and what they went through and he didn't
want to betray what other jurors were
thinking which I have to say we tried
many times I respected that Anthony I
respected that
and he wanted to say that this was
painful for everybody involved so I was
I was very very touched by him you know
he was selected for the jury January
17th the verdict came in Monday February
24th which is more than five weeks he
said I just want to get back to my life
that's what I want to my voice yeah yeah
people stalking you he's he's hoping
that will now come to an end he's not
interested in going on a media tour he
says that's so interesting why would
people stalk them what's the the
interest I mean well because they want
to get information they want to walk I
want to find out if it was a truly
affair people were fascinated and they
just want to know what he was thinking
yeah